Stanley druckenmiller was at Bloomberg
invest conference yesterday every single
time Stanley drucken Miller talks you
should listen he's one of the single
greatest investors in Wall Street
history he has compounded Capital at
more than 30 percent every single year
for three different decades now Stanley
druckenmiller had a lot to say and he
started out talking about the debt
currently the United States debt sits at
31 trillion it used to be at 15. but
Stanley points out that actually the
true debt is almost 200 trillion instead
of the 31 trillion dollar number that
everyone talks about here's what Stanley
had to say the debt went from 20
trillion to Thirty I'm sorry 15 trillion
to 31 trillion over that time that debt
and this is important because most
people don't understand it
um assumes he'll never be another
Medicare
or Social Security payment made 200
trillion is the present value as you've
calculated for the students not me
credible people Larry cutlerkoff and
others if you assume we're never going
to have another security or Medicare
repayment the debt is 31 trillion but if
you did your accounting like any
Corporation and you assume those
payments going to be made you have the
present value is probably around 200
trillion dollars now that commentary by
Stanley is obviously sobering but he had
a nice little joke where he started to
talk about the fiscal Gap and as he
points out it's an absurd idea that only
economists could come up with the fiscal
Gap is something that we have to
continue to pay attention to because it
says that taxation is not a path towards
actually balancing the budget here's
what Stanley thinks about this only
economists could come up with this term
is called fiscal Gap what is fiscal Gap
that's how much you would have to raise
taxes today
to guarantee the benefits you've
promised seniors in the future
it's 7.7 percent of GDP what is 7.7
percent of GDP mean
to actually pay for the entitlements we
promise in the future you'd have to
raise all taxes 40 percent today forever
or cut all spending 36 percent today
forever what I'm looking at here is this
stuff is borrowing from the future
you're going to crowd out private
Investments you're going to crowd out
the kind of investment that made us the
leader on all those kind of things now
as many of you know I listened to
another interview that Stanley did and
he suggested to read the book the price
of time by Edward Chancellor I read it
and it's a fantastic book that I also
highly suggest that you go read here's
Stanley talking about what he learned
from that book which goes all the way
back 500 years and looks at various
asset Bubbles and then is able to
connect the asset bubble to a period of
easy money beforehand when we have asset
bubbles they always lead to economic
chaos and catastrophe here's what
Stanley has to say looking at today's
current environment because the question
I have for you there is do you believe
that there are still many shoes to drop
as the Central Bank stays tight that's
my central case
um
ideal in the world of of risk reward
there's a 500 year history of asset
bubbles well documented in a book that
you had some issues with the price of
time and
basically it documents and I had already
known this about the last hundred years
but it's going on for 500 years every
time you've had a significant asset
bubble economic trouble way ahead but
yeah when you had 11 years of free money
um people do stupid things all you have
to do is look it up there about the
stupidest is somebody paid 80 billion
dollars for Dogecoin which was invented
as a joke I mean that can only happen in
the world of free money it also suppress
people worrying about the kind of stuff
I just talked about two or three minutes
ago because you keep rates at zero but
the fact that this was arguably the most
disruptive economic period we've had
since the late 1800s
and there were no bankruptcies
apparently they've started in the last
few weeks tells me there's a lot of
stuff under the hood when you go from
this kind of environment biggest
broadest asset bubble ever and then you
jack rates up 500 basis points in a year
I think the probabilities would suggest
that Silicon Valley Banks Bed Bath and
Beyond they're probably the tip of the
iceberg it's interesting to hear Stanley
talk about all of these different points
I tend to agree with them we obviously
had an asset bubble in 2020 leading into
2021 the Federal Reserve has done their
absolute best job to go ahead and
Destroy demand using their language but
they've done better job at destroying
investor demand than they have consumer
demand and so if the FED has already
tightened from 0 to 500 basis points and
they may continue to tighten likely the
bubble will continue to be deflated over
time now how bad it can get I don't know
your guess is as good as mine but what I
do know is that you've got to be
prepared you've got to have a strong
balance sheet you've got to try to
optimize for cash flow and you have to
be optimizing for optionality at the
moment don't go out and make big
purchases don't go out and sync all of
your money into any one investment
instead the name of the game is going to
be resilience over the coming 24 months
I think Stanley druckenmiller is ringing
the bell there's plenty of people who
think the worst of the pain is behind us
as he said he and his team believe that
there's another shoe to drop and I tend
to think that the probability is
increasing every single day that he may
be right if you haven't listened to the
full interview he did it with my friend
sonali basic over at Bloomberg I highly
suggest you go listen to Stanley's full
commentary he's always a great listen
and I always learn a ton every single
time that he speaks in conclusion
Stanley druckenmiller is saying what
many people have said for decades this
time is not different don't get too
cocky don't get too arrogant don't start
to believe that it is because of history
is our God asset bubbles come but asset
bubbles go and usually portfolios get
hurt